let's take the concept of universal
income I had to think about why do I
hate this so much it's predicated on the
idea that you deserve the right to a
basic universal income regardless of
worker ability sounds good
but how does it work it only works by
the grace of others by the grace of
others who did the work and who had
their spoils taken from them at gunpoint
nothing that you think you deserve when
you trace it back far enough can stem
from anything other than the grace of
someone else I wanted to talk to you
guys about a couple of things today I
know I'm not supposed to read the
comment sections and I usually don't on
social media obviously people who who
are my club members that's a little bit
different we can interact people there
but that 2q Matic can you bring up the
overlay here this is one thing that I
did see recently in the Amy Schumer
special this person said I would love to
join but haven't taken care of my mom
for the last few years two weeks ago
informed us that she only has three to
six months left COPD sucks I'll
eventually join the support there
meaning us but for this time YouTube
will have to suffice and this other
person just user net we've eliminated
any private info here though they did
post it on YouTube ill-advised god bless
you I'd like to send you the money to
sign up for mug club and if you want
read the rest these comments can bring
it down to keeping adding people I can
see if you're listening to audio version
I encourage you to go watch the video
first off we're gonna get you we
appreciate that our fans are trying to
support each other we're gonna get you
obviously hooked up with with Michael
we'll make sure we'll find your email
will track you down and we'll make sure
that you're taking care we really
appreciate the sentiment but seeing our
fans you act that way knowing that that
that is true it's indicative of the bulk
of you who tuned in to this show it
really does you know I know as I get
older it sounds but it really does warm
my heart I think it warms all of our
cockles yeah you shouldn't use that term
but I used it anyway yeah well you
should be you should be but not because
of that so two things I wanted to talk
about today the first thing is the
steaming others for serving other people
first so let me tell you the story this
last weekend I went to Florida with my
wife to visit the in-laws club main loss
great great people I'm very fortunate in
that respect the first day we were
fighting quite a bit
arguing quite a bit and this tends to I
don't know if you've noticed it's the
first day of vacation if this tends to
happen the first day of vacation like my
wife and I when we used to live in
different states before we were married
the first day we would always be arguing
and usually the last day
and I think it's because of one brace of
you Minh beings are selfish and so you
have your way of doing things or your
expectations and then you're locked in a
room with someone basically or a tube in
the sky and you're staying in the same
room and you're in law's apartments and
you find out that you really can't do
things the way that you've been wanting
to do them in the next I will since the
next two days and our trip we're great
because we consciously decided that
rather than push and pull and bump heads
that we would serve each other first and
this is a challenge I would like to
issue to everyone out there because I we
get a lot of life advice questions we do
the segment's behind that they pay well
I want to challenge you from one week
one week to focus on serving other
people and that brings me to my second
point and one of the thing might be a
little bit uncomfortable for a lot of
people serving others first thing of
others first it also gets you out of the
rhythm that we all fall into of getting
what we deserve you can call it
entitlement we all feel it to a certain
degree we're also focused on getting
what we deserve on what we rightfully
have coming to us only if you were
actually thought about that there were
other comments on the amy schumer
special teaser which i'll be honest
about piss me off a little bit people
complaining about the fact that mug club
exists refuse any why can't you just
upload it all for free I'm not paying
for I'm not paying for my Co I don't
have the money and when I read that I
got pissed for a few reasons
some are valid and I realized some of
them are I own issues valid ones for
example we literally couldn't upload
yesterday's Amy Schumer review we test
it on a private stream YouTube
immediately struck the video and revoke
this private channels live-streaming
privileges it's not just about D
monetization anymore its outright
banning sometimes we simply can't get to
show up you saw it with the Oscars the
trailer itself d monetized the second it
was up writing down it's from worse than
that so they just let you upload the
review yes it's it's it's not even just
about you not receiving notifications
even though you opted in two three four
or five times some of you out there so
please bookmark the page and keep
checking in sometimes we just can't do
another thing we've always created
exclusive content like The Daily Show
for people who are Hmong Club members
because we've wanted to provide everyone
with more free content mud clip is only
one anyone in here survives so that's
why not everything goes up for free and
sometimes I'll read these comments and
I think well you know what maybe you
know maybe you don't deserve this show
maybe if you don't join my club this
show might go away if you're not willing
to step up this show will go away
forever you'll log into your Facebook
and that's what you deserve but if I'm
being honest
neither do I I don't deserve this I
don't deserve this show
I don't deserve for the I don't serve
the many of you out there to give me
your hard earned money so that I and
everyone here can continue to create and
perform this show for you you know
sometimes this show is hard sometimes
yeah people burn out sometimes I run
into health issues but oh my god I don't
deserve to get up every day and work
sure maybe 10 14 hours on creating
something but creating something that
people love for people who love me who
love this show the people you who've
created this platform who've made this
channel the number one conservative
channel in the history of YouTube
why am I to think about this unless I'm
reading the comment that's why you don't
read the comment section I am I getting
pissed because some people want to rip
our content for free I don't deserve any
of this
it's a blessing and when I think about
what I deserve have you ever really
thought about that I mean really thought
about it when I think about it I'll tell
you scary when I think of throughout my
life the mistakes I make the people of
hurt whether on purpose or by accident
the ripple effects some of my misdeeds
may have created when I add it all up I
really want what I deserve
do you do any of us and yeah listen to
you the guy girl or Z who doesn't want
to support the show you do you deserve
for this show to go away you deserve to
log into your YouTube account and go oh
it's completely gone I never get to
watch it again but you won't that's not
good you know why because of grace
because of the grace of other people
because other people have paid the bill
for you and just like you saw in that
comment earlier it's from someone who's
willing to help another person out my
point is this none of us really want to
get what we actually deserve any of us
we all like to think about what we've
earned too what we're entitled little
even sometimes a little Joy's in life
that we deserve about treating yourself
but what about that does it go both ways
what about the Justice what about the
punishment you think about what you
deserve there you know what most if not
all of us have
had to truly bear the brunt of what we
deserve and the only reason we don't is
because of grace now listen I'm a
Christian okay so I believe and I'm
thankful for God's grace when it comes
to the ultimate justice and Punishment
but let's take it out of the medical
metaphysical sense here okay and your
day-to-day you don't receive what you
truly deserve often only through the
grace of others usually by many others
who lift your burdens who serve your
needs and you probably don't even
recognize it I know most of us certainly
don't appreciate it it's why I see
entitlement mindsets is so pervasively
evil you don't deserve I mean hard truth
here you don't deserve your job you have
won by the grace of someone else who
created a product which stems from the
grace of someone else who created a
company which turns on the grace of
someone who create an industry which
stems from the grace of someone who
graced the world with an idea you don't
deserve you don't you do not deserve
healthcare or an average life expectancy
that's 20 to 30 years longer than your
great-grandfather you receive it by the
grace of someone else who is providing
the procedure that you need or or the
grace of someone who pioneered modern
medicine the grace of someone who took a
risk that you yourself would likely
probably never be willing to take and I
know right now we're talking about money
exchanging hands and so people will
light up the comment section saying well
it's not by grace it's a profit motive
but that's not entirely true and by the
way you're missing the point
either way let's go smaller with it you
don't deserve that coffee your wife or
your husband maybe this morning you
often you don't deserve then wavering
love or support that they give you you
receive it through grace it's for the
same simple concept by the way that
mandated entitlements destroy a nation
take the concept let's take the concept
of universal income I had to think about
why do I hate this so much it's
predicated on the idea that you deserve
the right to a basic universal income
regardless of worker ability sounds good
but how does it work it only works by
the grace of others by the grace of
others who did the work and who had
their spoils taken from them at gunpoint
nothing that you think you deserve when
you trace it back far enough can stem
from anything other than the grace of
someone else and this brings me back to
my first point just I think entitlement
robs people of their spirit of their
soul your
mindset of entitlement of what you
deserve Rob's you of truly living a
fulfilling life don't believe me try
this for a week
write this down okay take some grab a
pen and paper if you're listening on the
audio version all of next week live your
life day to day to bestow grace upon and
serve others for the whole week in other
words this week first thing when you
wake up think of how you can serve
people you love the most what do you
what do you usually do grab yourself a
cup of coffee go for a job nope not this
week you're going to bring your wife a
cup of coffee you're going to get up
earlier and help prepare your husband so
that he can go for a jog before work if
you find yourself getting frustrated
with things not going your way okay
stop and ask yourself why your wife your
husband your dad your mom whoever it is
the next guy down the line might be
frustrated and helped him to pave his
way do you often find yourself getting
sad depressed even talked about this I
struggle with it find someone else who's
even more set someone who has even more
of a reason to be depressed you know
they're there
cheer them up one week that's what I'm
asking you to do for one week I want you
to flip the switch on the day-to-day of
making sure that you get what you
deserve and make sure that you are
living a life to serve others one week
do that every waking moment tell me
doesn't change your life tell me doesn't
change your entire perspective comment
let me know the fact is this if for the
people out there who commented on if you
don't join my club and support this
program listen you you don't deserve
this show anything that you enjoy is
enjoyed by the grace of others who've
paid the bill just as certainly I don't
deserve your support I don't you pay my
bills you pay all of our bills you feed
all of our families I don't deserve the
blessing that is the ability to employ a
dozen people and to create this show for
you every day I receive support by your
grace
and I try to serve you as best as I can
every day and you know what I hope will
be around here another decade from now
able to serve you through your grace and
more importantly I really want to see
more of what I saw in that comment
section of people helping someone else
out more of you mug club or subscriber
supporters bestowing grace on each other
because you know what that's what makes
you different from a lot of these other
channels it's not about what you deserve
it's about what you give one week use
that comment as a model try it out let
me know how it turns out for you Here I
am
looking from my mug in a button-down how
often do you see this never so do me a
favor and yourself click one of these
videos playing in one of these boxes
here or a subscribe hit a notification
bell also because subscriptions don't
really mean a whole lot if you really
want to support the show join my club if
you don't then there's no helping you